welcome to this video playing Peregrine
64 so I'm playing the reggio opening
here the original I'm ready let's see ok
it's never and taking on c4 could
transpose to the Catalan now ok let's go
to the Catalan I can play the Holy Ghost
variation but I mean let's see what
paragory does does he play the line that
I also play against mr. williger's all
the time I would really like to get
paired against stalling us at the moment
he's on 2600 reading which is
ridiculously high in five minute and I
mean even though I don't score well
against him i think if i play a match
with 300 points me being somewhat
underrated I would win points for sure
yeah it's taking a long time you have
oxy 8 is the normal move and also very
normal looking is everything okay with
you buddy yeah he's connected am I
connected yes yeah maybe yet to do
something answer phone call us all out
there are a couple of lines here if I'm
not mistaken but should be four is a
move c5 is the main move that also is
plate and then we really understood why
white is playing what ya twins you three
or queen d 2 1 I think this is mostly
played and let's go in see 10 or 20 2
i'm sure Bishop b4 Quincy one this is
the line there but don't ask me why this
is played and simply don't know ok this
is also seen
let's go look see fire maybe I'm
confusing things I probably am that
doesn't look so great anyway let's just
play quickly and try to convey the
impression that I'm knowing what i'm
doing and take stakes 95 then take
anyway no t5 Bishop g2 night see for
Bishop f1 it seems to loose material in
95 Bishop g2 let's see for Bishop
everyone who doesn't look good
Roxy a drug seattle seahawks see ya here
Roxy for that's 95 so that wasn't
possible here thought I might have a
little something because of his weakest
see porn I day for I go be three it's
the very dry
yes to the very George
at least what I happens I have more time
definitely so how to go about this maybe
Roxy to make sure that everything is
protected and now get the King into the
game oking at three King III legs not
sure about f5 that was helpful so p3
Knight b6 simply going back I guess 92
is going C 30 no I guess he is
hero p8 look-see for my pistol alone
something
and surprising check I thought that this
should be still quite good 95 I guess I
mean quite good could be an
understatement you success hanging in 97
is a threat e 6 is hanging as well
it's very awkward yeah just taking a six
I guess hmm I didn't like to trade
nights it's just a ticket I can go to e4
maybe just going up up to you five check
hmm okay I don't want to give a material
to be honest what's interesting to go up
to you five but this is simple and
pretty good I can just go 95 next black
resins no metals I did he should
equalize him somehow but it wasn't so
straightforward queen d 4 is rubbish of
course I have to go look C 1 this is the
normal move I still blame and forgot
about this and tier Queen f6 is good for
black just attacking be 2 or Quincy aid
okay after that it is equal again and
here you took with the poor now I mean
there is no particular reason not to
take with the noid rook see one it looks
a bit awkward but he always has this and
he covers c8 so something like this is
no problem whatsoever and yeah this is
it's not necessary to take with the pond
and here i have slide pool because of
the pawn structure it's nothing that
loose should lose the game but
it can get problematic here he already i
don't know Luke v8 is a mistake quite
clearly but I'm approaching it's not
it's not very very nice Jan this is just
a flat-out window plus to point
something yeah it was a typical Catalan
game where I'm white is this a little
bit more was a little bit more
comfortable after he made those mistakes
um I played the opening badly though I
have to go look see one year this is
just much better this is jeff way it is
plato black and black it's a equalizing
at the end that could have cost me
dearly queen f6 is very annoying to
Sutekh him yeah queen before I played
that far too quickly okay thanks for
watching